[Music]
this women's history month our new
series we're calling it changing the
game is profiling extraordinary women
making an impact now and on future
generations as beyonce says who runs the
world girls this morning we're going to
introduce you to one of the pioneers
behind the modernicobot vaccine her name
is dr kazmikia corbett she's taken on
vaccine hesitancy and she spent her
career fighting for equality in
healthcare landing her a spot on the
cover of time magazine you go dr corbett
the bill and melinda gates foundation
provided funding for the studies that dr
corbett contributed to
melinda french gates has long admired
corbett from afar which is why she chose
her to be part of our series jamie yuka
sat down with both women at the
non-profit e-bell that's in los angeles
which has a mission to educate and
uplift women
it's still very surreal to me i still
cannot believe we as a team did that i
was told that i was one of the first
people to open the vial of a vaccine at
just 36 years old dr kazmikia corbett
worked night and day with a team of
scientists developing moderna's covit 19
vaccine in record time why is dr corbett
a game changer oh my gosh she's an
absolute game changer because when she
was at the national institutes of health
she really laid down the backbone for
the covet 19 vaccine
being honored by people like you and
having people say that out loud is
certainly so surreal what's also surreal
listening to dr corbett's timeline once
covet 19 was discovered it was almost
from january 6th on no one got any sleep
have you slept lately
i slept on the plane here
all of us have now become familiar with
the term global pandemic both these
women say what motivates them is the
dedication to improving people's health
around the world because we had a whole
number of virologists and
epidemiologists and had many many many
partners in the field we jumped on it to
say my gosh
whatever gets developed here needs to be
done for the whole world and mine not
just the high-income countries do you
think we're going to get better about
seeing those disparities and fixing that
i was an undergrad when the hiv pandemic
was in an uproar and one thing that i
saw was that it really only mattered
what neighborhood you lived in what we
have to do is continue to keep the
conversation open
because the same types of disparities
that we saw with cobit 19 we saw with
hiv we've seen with so many other
diseases working toward equal
distribution of the vaccine was just the
beginning i hope you guys are rested
and peaceful
and healthy and vaccinated corbett has
spent the last two years encouraging
anyone and everyone to get the shot you
said something you said vaccine
hesitancy and i know you don't like
using that term
you like vaccine inquisitiveness why by
calling them vaccine inquisitive
you
give them the liberty to be the
scientist actually ask the question
ask the question and
if i can i will answer it for you a lot
of these people have just never had
their opinions heard before you know
what i also heard in that though is that
as a woman young woman you are allowed
to have a voice that is one of my daily
affirmations
is it yes i am strong i am beautiful i
have a voice say it out loud every
single day you'll start to believe it
and then when someone doesn't believe it
you won't care
there's a lot of doubt when you're
creating something new and you
absolutely have to have a team because
then you have each other's back when you
hit a dead end or somebody else then
maybe figures out the piece you couldn't
figure out right it's almost like you're
working a puzzle corbett found that very
first puzzle piece pretty early on i was
16 and i wanted a new pair of shoes that
my parents were like no
you're not getting those
and if you want to have a job then it
must have an educational slant and so i
went and i got a job and worked in this
laboratory at the university of north
carolina and i just fell in love and did
your parents affirm to you that you
could be anything you wanted to be all
the time my dad used to say oh i don't
care what you are just be the best at it
i had that exact same message from both
my parents you can be anything you want
to be
you should go definitely you're going to
be college going and we will take on the
debt i remember talking to my dad and he
said
just go where you're going to be loved
and it it was almost immediate that i
knew where i needed to be in the next
step you just don't see as many girls in
technology and in science and certainly
you don't see as many people of color
and i really feel like it's hard to be
what you can't see and so i think you're
a huge role model i don't think i know
you're a huge role model to so many
young girls you know it is an honor to
be inspirational
for sure
wow wow wow melinda french gates and dr
corbett a one-two punch i i love the two
of them together
i think it's really great and vlad and i
both said this at the same time when
they said she's 30 cents
wow if she did nothing else for the rest
of her career she would have already had
a historic career and that's an amazing
thing at age 36. i also love her daily
affirmations yes i'm strong i am
beautiful i have a voice i've always
been somebody who's like do i really
need to repeat daily affirmations to
myself
there is power in this absolutely yes
she said after a while you start to
believe and if people don't believe it
it won't matter yeah i wrote that down
too
i have a voice i hope it applies to all
of us yeah i'm going to try it i'm going
to try that nicely done yeah really nice
piece really great and she's definitely
paving the road for other girls going
into science it's a it's a pipeline that
needs to be full and it is now